[موسيقى]
كان يقول انه شكل السياسي نظام السياسي
مبني على ثلاثه جغرافيا طبيعه الارض
والمناخ والعادات والتقليد لو تحضر ليبيا
بين السنوسي وسيف الاسلام القذافي تجد
الكفته راجحي لسيف الاسلام القذافي لانه
هناك في حنين لهذا في العراق لو تاتي بين
الملكيه العراقيه او نظام صدام حسين
الحنين لنظام صدام حسين اكبر في تونس لما
تتكلم على النظام الملكي اللي كان قبل
الحبيب بورقيبه او نظام ابن علي ابو رقيبه
الحنين عند التوانسه الاغلبيه هو الحنين
لنظام ابن علي لانه ابن علي 2010 كان
الدوله الاولى في التنميه
[موسيقى]
هناك مثل صيني يقول بانه ليس مهما ان يكون
القط ابيض او اسود المهم ان يصطاد الفئران
وربما هذا المقوله تنطبق ايضا حول طبيعه
الانظمه السياسيه لانه يمكن ان تكون انظمه
ملكيه دستوريه ويمكن ان تكون تحقق نجاحات
وتقدم جوابا اجتماعيا واقتصاديا بالنسبه
لشعوبها وايضا هناك انظمه جمهوريه يمكن ان
تقدم هذه الاجوبه بكل تاكيد يوم ازمه
الديمقراطيه في العالم ككل وليس فقط في
العالم العربي ان هذا الشكل الديمقراطيه
ما بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه شاخ اليوم
[موسيقى]